Whoopi Goldberg who is who she has
literally become a human whoopee cushion
if you squeeze her noxious gases comes
out of her mouth I'm sorry that was
rather vile but she is just absolutely
awful here she is on The View with fake
conservative Alyssa Farah Alyssa Farah
Alyssa I think I've said this to you uh
well I've definitely tweeted it at you
but I just want to be clear about this
Alyssa if you're watching
um you're getting let's say a million
bucks to be on The View for a year or
two there'll be probably a million you
probably have like a two-year deal it's
probably about a million million and a
half that's good cash most people would
like to make a million or a million a
half would you guys be interested in
that that would be something okay I
can't help you there but that would be
saying it most people would want you're
selling your soul to do it you are not
defending conservatism or any Republican
idea or anything and whoopee and joy and
the rest of them the second they are
done sucking your soul out of you which
you're giving to them on a plate anyway
they they will never invite you to a
wedding or to an event or to their house
or anything else anyway here is human
whoopee cushion Whoopi Goldberg and
complete conservative sellout Allison
Farah going after Nikki Haley for the
same exact thing that Don Lemon had to
take a couple days off for
a new
new duration
compared to DC though compared to DC
that's a new generation but it's not a
new generation she may be she may be
younger than most of those people but
her rhetoric is the same she's saying
the same BS and I love the young kid but
you know what the only way you're going
to get younger people to run dude is if
you're out there talking to people and
saying run don't sit here and say we
need it to look like us we know that we
know that but we're not going to vote
for people who don't have our best
interests at heart let me do it the last
part there we're not going to vote for
people who don't have our best interests
in heart what did Ronald Reagan say the
eight scariest words in the English
language I'm from the government and I'm
here to help these people want the
government to be their daddy they want
the government to be their God I do not
go away from me government I don't like
you very much I don't need you yes if
there is a natural disaster it would be
nice if somebody could help out and I
would like some roads in a border beyond
that I really don't want anything to do
with you people uh but the fact that
Whoopi is going off on Nikki Haley's age
now first off Whoopi is 67. Nikki is 51.
now I'm actually not attacking Whoopi
for her age she has all of the wrong
ideas absolutely all of the wrong ideas
it's very sad watching what Bishop used
to be a great actress like everyone
loved Whoopi 20 years ago there was no
one in America that wasn't like oh whoop
he's a great actress she's funny as hell
she does the the comedy specials on HBO
and she's in Ghost and yeah what was the
well give me a Whoopi Goldberg movie uh
Sister Act thank you sister act two back
in the action or whatever the hell that
was uh and she's just become obliviating
buffoon but she's going after Nikki
Haley and saying that she's not a new
generation she's actually technically
wrong about that uh Nikki Haley is Gen X
Gen X meaning you were born in the mid
60s basically into the late 70s a little
bit into the early 80s I'm 46 years old
I'm right in the middle I was born in 76
I am right in the middle of Gen X Gen X
should be in charge right now
[Music]